oh yeah
oh cela fait 1 an qu'ils attendent ça
après avoir rassemblé les précieux 13000
€ nécessaires au raid les membres de
l'équipage quat Trophy sont enfin prêts
à se lancer dans le 4L Trophy super
excité j'en ai pas dormi de la nuit euh
donc les préparatifs là on a été pr au
dernier moment on est dans les sarting
blocks c'est parti quoi la préparation
de la voiture a été peaufinée jusqu'au
dernier moment dans les moindres détails
avec la PAE de l'éclairage porté des
sièges baqués au système d'allumage
électrique avec bouton poussoir
l'équipage a pensé à son confort entre
les dunes et le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est qu'il n'y a plus beaucoup de
place dans le coffre on a les petits
tiroirs en bas qu'on a canadenassé pour
tout ce qui est objets personnel et et
de valeur comme ça on aura pas de souci
sur les bivoques ou sur les étapes après
on a dans les dans les les sacs de sport
avec toutes les fournitures humanitaires
donc sportif paramédical et et scolair
pour les les petits marocains et après
on a le jerican d'essence tous les
liquides pour la voiture mais à plus de
50 ans la mécanique est déjà capricieuse
on n pas fait 100 m qu'on avait deux
trois petits bruits qui venaient aux
oreilles assez assez bizarre donc on va
se poser deux trois questions on va en
parler mais normalement tout est bon on
a fait une bonne préparation nous a bien
aidé donc normalement c'est parfait le
départ officiel du raid sera donné le 14
février à MIDH à Poitier avant le feu
vert un dernier au revoir à la famille
avant de rouler vers la plus grande
aventure de leur vie